New research suggests "broken homes" may not
be broken, after all.
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and we've
long been taught to believe that the nuclear
family is the key to long-term happiness.
But a new study says that may not be entirely
true!
A group of researchers from the UK analyzed
data from over 12,000 7-year-old children,
and found that those living with a step-parent
or a single parent, were just as happy as
those living with two biological parents.
Researchers separated the children into 3
different groups: those living with 2 biological
parents, those living with one biological
parent and one step-parent, and those living
with a single biological parent.
After adjusting for factors like social class
and neighborhood affluence - researchers asked
the children to rate how happy they were,
by reporting they were either "happy all the
time" or happy "sometimes or never."
And the results were exactly the same for
all 3 groups: 36% of children said they were
happy 'all the time' and 64% said they were
happy 'sometimes or never.'
They even repeated the study for older children,
ages 11-15, and the results were almost exactly
the same.
Jenny Chanfreau, the lead scientist on the
project, says this study proves it's not the
family composition that matters - but the
quality of the relationships at home.
Factors like getting along with their siblings,
having friends, having fun with the family,
and not being bullied at school - were all
linked with a higher likelihood of being happy
all the time.
I am sure this will come as a relief to some
of you single parents out there - so if your
child is unhappy - just remember.
It's not all about you.
And hey - while we're talking about kids,
did you know that auto accidents are the number
one killer of US teens?
It's a terrifying statistic, and that's why
Toyota is taking part in the Toyota Teen Driver
Video Challenge.
A few weeks ago, they asked high school students
to submit short videos that promote safe driving,
and the judges have now narrowed it down to
the top 10 submissions.
From now until April 30, you can go to toyotateendriver.com/vote
and vote every day for your favorite video.
One grand prize winner will receive $15,000
and have their video re-shot by the Discovery
crew.
So head over toyotateendriver.com/vote - and
you, too, can help promote safe driving.
As always, if you have questions or comments
about this episode - leave in the comments
below, and for more episodes of Dnews - subscribe
here.